notre monde c'est ce qu'on dit creamer
hier elle tous les jours je lis les
commentaires qu'il ya sur la dernière
vidéo que j'ai sorti j'avoue que très
souvent je rigole seul parce que croyez
moi dans cet espace commentaires il se
passe des trucs vraiment épique soit des
gens disent des conneries soit ya des
débats qui n'ont pas lieu d'être enfin
bref il ya toutes sortes de choses et je
me suis dit [ __ ] mais ici en vidéo on
lisait les commentaires tous ensemble et
constater les barbes tout simplement
c'est parti pourquoi squeeze un bras
plus musclée que l'autre alors je sais
déjà tout ce que vous allez penser
bastien la masturbation gauchère quatre
ans de célibat
parce qu'il utilise plus la souris que
le clavier oui à fuck parce qu'il
utilise khadra pour pouvoir se censurer
il n'est pas célibataire donc je pense
qu'il fait du tennis voilà enfin
quelqu'un de sensé un wait je ne fais
pas de thé vice premier dislike à amara
like boys je vous remercie tous ok pas
content ok à la répartie de ce mec est
incroyable kw à 7 minutes 07 fermer les
yeux xd alors on va voir ça oui pour moi
c'est juste des mecs qui soulève des
meubles un peu lourd et qui déménage pas
pour vous c'est bizarre ya un phénomène
que j'ai remarqué qu'il ya sur toutes
les vidéos youtube c'est le mec qui peut
faire sa pub sur les vidéos des autres
mais qui va dire un petit compliment
invente pour que ça passe un peu mieux
par exemple il dit cette vidéo et roanne
dr veux voir ma chaîne
c'est génial c'est sérieux t'a fait une
vidéo spéciale un abonné mdr bah oui bah
moi comme mon père sable à ma chaîne
aussi j'étais content il existe un
bouton qu'on appuie dessus tu dis mon
gars arrête de se permet ce bouton mon
gars bon gars mon gars j'aime squeeze et
les trains moi aussi j'aime bien les
trains je t'adore et et vidéos sont trop
courts merci
je mens je m'en vais autre disparition
coucou weezy tu peux jouer ce jeu sony
qui fait flipper s'te plaît et un mec
qui répond c'est ta photo de profil qui
me fait flipper moi je n'y coupent et
moi personnellement à l'ump ça me fait
un peu peur tout ce qui est malhonnête
ou bextra ça fait un peu flipper et y
répond ok tu serais pas ça s'appelle une
tulipe j'en ai 3 bat plus dupes où passe
quand même bien sûr plus l'ex apple
chaton roux et devraient tous minutes
aujourd'hui et les photos d'une poupée
l'impression qu'elle veut nous tuer tous
quoi vous allez mourir
les gars mon pc bugs et ça m'ouvre des
pages de pub c'est quelqu'un pourrait
m'aider merci de me répondre
donc là on est sur youtube forum tu as
un problème point coop agostino
migliavacca nous dit mammifères bitches
voilà donc je passe cet homme à la
grippe aviaire mais en tout cas il a un
petit problème avec les musiques de
skyrim ça rajoute un côté de woking
épique mais c'est vrai que la musique de
ce qui arrive
tu peux faire n'importe quelle action
située cette musique ça transforme ça en
quelque chose de complètement épique par
exemple mais du déodorant sandoval king
avec de whiting
[ __ ] mais là je vais pas trop ce pays
pendant deux mois et demi aux médias
thomson trop cool de la mort qui tue
fantasmagorique mais qui a répété sa 10
fois d'affilée c'est mon record
médiate aux fans trop cool de la mort
que ça me casse les couilles au [ __ ]
mais j'ai tellement rigolé ah ah ah ah
j'en pleure encore qui est qui et qui
olalala des bars alors est ce que quand
cette personne
rigole devant son ordi elle fait
vraiment ce à quoi bon je suis content
de voir que la vidéo tapis en tout cas
m6 retire à la fin on dirait mon frère
de 24 ans qui fait le bébé doc est amer
voilà ces deux jours par les la
méchanceté gratuite vers l'arrière fait
du tout attendu coup l'autre répond quoi
c'est bon tu ne le fait pas la morale ma
cousine est morte alors je te plaît
arrête aussi horribles à ça devrait pas
exister des conversations comme ça sans
déconner ça mais tellement banal os
c'est là tout le monde s'en veut d'avoir
rigolé ont d'ailleurs vu le hockey ta
mère tout à fait non mais j'ai pas j'ai
pas rigoler mois quand il avait croqué
ta merde ça se fait pas c'est pas gentil
plus plus plus tu te sens bien
non j'ai sniffé waterston car au
challenge des geeks des hoquets pourquoi
besoin d'être là parce qu'ils se noient
dans lego à merci non pour moi il vaut
mieux des lego en fait c'est ça que
j'aimais
c'est bon tu as un mec qui vomit des
lego voilà que oui quand j'étais petit
je vomissais très souvent des lego alors
bon je nique tous les fournisseurs du
monde est quelqu'un lui répond c'est
bien voilà est-ce que le mec qui a écrit
ses biens dont ce mardi il était comme
ça il voulait sortir du monde et laponie
mi temps du khat est malade n'a pas fait
trop chaud pour établissement chez lui à
production des squeeze je vais venir te
tuer cette nuit mouahaha en fait c'était
une menace plus à l'écart non partie en
fourrière weezy ta gueule 1 1 1 1 il ya
une fuite de points d'interrogation
personnes à peu près ce qui s'est passé
qu'on ait dû sucer la [ __ ] qbe 10 pour
être aussi compté vidéos sont à chier
comme maman de ta gueule mdrr
bon alors déjà est-ce qu on entoure dans
ta phrase chaque fois au quai plus qu à
tort comme ça c'est la cause car le
bastard intervient jalousie
analphabétisme tattoo pour toi mec
atif je m'en fous vos com sont inutiles
quelqu'un parce que j'étais quelqu'un
peut faire un procès merci on doit
ouvrir une section sur youtube qui
s'appellerait commentaires contenders
volet c'est que des mecs dans les
commentaires qui se classe voilà toute
la journée ils sont là juste de chez
rage non seulement deux abonnés non un
million de fois plus vous ultime du bac
à 2014 séquestrés par des maths bas
jusqu'à preuve du contraire bon j'ai
fait un bac es que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire un million x 2 ça fait 2
millions
et pourtant ça fait combien millions
soit 2 autant pour moi j'ai mal compris
allez l'humiliation tu apprendras qu'en
plus il ya kevin 18 400 kits le monde un
peu le moral
pas grave si c'est grave si je sais
compter plutôt les trois soeurs
siamoises avec trois paires de seins
trois mois plus tard mais ce mec est le
plus gros perdant du rwanda beauport là
on a des gars les a cassés sur un métier
qu'est ce qui t'arrive là tu as plus de
mouches waouh je suis en train de me
dire que sur youtube j'avais peut-être
créer un espace multi commentaire voilà
tous les gens qui ont des soins peu
dangereux se retrouve ses idées mais
rentrent terminologie de mon bateau
provient de lire la suite 360 qui adore
en fait tu écrivais une serre dachau de
procès et d'ouvrir openoffice tu as
ouvert youtube couette et cardan tromper
de d'endroits mais bon le mec mais stop
là en fait tous les bugs youtube qu'on a
depuis annoncé de sa faute quoi s'il
écrit des commentaires de 400 lignes
sans déconner bon une part de l'agencé
de la fin de cette vidéo dans l'espace
commentaires de mes vidéos youtube
j'espère sera plus si c'est le cas ne
l'effraie pas aimé la vidéo ça fera
vraiment plaisir
aujourd'hui envie de faire une vidéo un
petit peu spécial et je me suis dit que
tous les jours je rigole
voilà en regardant l'espace contenu de
youtube parce qu'il ya plein de trucs et
pitt ça me fait plaisir de faire cette
vidéo de faire un truc qui change un
petit peu d'habitude j'ai ça vous aura
fait plaisir aussi
encore merci d'être plus de deux
millions trois cent mille personnes
abonnées à ma chaîne youtube c'est
carrément un homme juste incroyable et
on se retrouve dans une nouvelle vidéo
vous êtes top shot monde dit
j'étais entrain décédé là
[Musique]
s
ce